almost every year Tim Cook comes out on
stage for Apple spring event and says
good morning and welcome back to Apple
Park and this time it's gonna be
legendary so in this video I'm gonna
tell you guys exactly what you should
expect at this month's event and what
you absolutely shouldn't so let's get
started just like last year I expect
Apple to talk about their TV plus
service and show off some brand new
trailers probably including season two
of severance which they actually gave us
a sneak peek of at last year's September
event but that's not what you guys care
about you guys care about the Apple
products so let's get into those now
obviously every single year Apple
releases brand new colors for the iPhone
lineup including for the Pro Models and
the regular ones like the green color
that we got last year for both of them
they also always give us brand new
spring colors in terms of their iPhone
cases and their Apple watch bands but in
terms of the actual products I know a
lot of you think that we're going to be
getting Apple's VR headset and that's
probably because of Ming shaquo's leak
back in January saying that the mixed
reality headset is likely to debut at
either the spring media event or WWDC
however just a couple of weeks ago Mark
German came out and confirmed that there
is a delay and this headset is not
coming until June at Apple's WWDC event
and that makes the most sense because
that's for developers so they need to
show it off to people who actually make
the VR software and apps so it makes
perfect sense for WWDC and then now
moving into different Mac products a lot
of you guys are excited for the iMac
specifically the update to the 24 inch
because the Mac Mini just got the M2
Chip which is great but I have some bad
news for you guys a couple of weeks ago
Mark German confirmed that the new iMac
24 inch is not coming until late 2023 at
the earliest which means that it's not
going to be coming with an M2 Chip
update and he actually told us that a
very long time ago back in April of 2022
he said the iMac with M3 chip is already
in the works which hinted that the M2
model was going to be skipped completely
and Mark German has been hinting at that
for a while now like in December when he
said that the new Macbook Pro Models
would be launching in early 2023 but the
iMac would only be possible later in the
year and then he confirmed that the new
Macbook Air and iMac would be coming
with a three nanometer M3 chip which I'm
personally very excited about but that
of course is not going to be ready until
later in the year no way it's happening
at the spring event and then for some
reason some of you guys think that the
iPad Pro is going to be updated at this
spring event which is not happening no
way okay because it just got updated
back in October of last year and it's
usually on a one and a half year cycle
so looking at the latest rumors from
Korea's ET news the iPad Pro is gonna
have an OLED display an awesome one and
it's only going to be coming next year
so don't wait for that and then on top
of that makes your quo did say back in
January that the iPad Mini is going to
be refreshed but likely early next year
so definitely not this year absolutely
not at this spring event and going even
further Ross young has been saying that
we're expecting multiple OLED iPads in
2024 which I believe means that the iPad
Air is also not coming this year and
definitely not the spring event because
it was released at the spring event last
year and it's also on a one and a half
year cycle so that means late 2023 is
the early earliest we should see the
iPad Air and now perhaps the biggest one
a lot of you guys are waiting for the
Max studio update with the M2 Ultra chip
and I gotta admit that this one actually
makes sense because this is what Apple
did last time with the M1 family of
chips they released the M1 then the M1
Pro and Max for the MacBook Pros and
then the M1 Ultra for the Mac Studio so
you would expect them to do the same
thing this year with the M2 family but
unfortunately I don't think so and Mark
German actually back in early February
said that Apple may not launch an
updated Mac Studio with M2 Ultra due to
similarity with the upcoming Mac Pro so
basically it is going to be way too
similar so it doesn't make sense for
Apple to release it as a cheaper product
or alternative to the Mac Pro which they
definitely want you to spend the money
on and the reason for that is because
back in December Mark German confirmed
that the M2 extreme chip is likely
canceled yes the chip with four dies not
two like the ultra but four which was
what we were very excited for for the
Mac Pro no longer coming so it's going
to be limited to the M2 Ultra so why
would Apple release both the Max studio
with M2 Ultra and the M2 Ultra Mac Pro
they would Clash so because of that I
believe that the Mac Studio is going to
be skipped and it's not coming until the
M3 extreme is ready for the Mac Pro and
that way they can have the M3 Ultra for
the Mac Studio which sucks for you guys
but it's going to be amazing when it
does come and now let's finally get into
the MacBook Air and this is very
exciting but before I get into that I've
got to talk about the best macsafe
iPhone case I've ever seen the magic
stand case from our partner cascu not
only is it surprisingly slim and durable
but it comes with a very strong 48
Magnet Max a ring that actually doubles
as a stand just pull out the ring and
use it as a finger grip or as a stand
for watching videos at any angle between
40 and 120 degrees and the best part is
that it folds away completely flush on
the back so you can still use it with
your max save Chargers and accessories
so check out the link and all the
discount info in the video description
below now speaking of the MacBook Air I
know some of you guys are thinking that
the M3 chip MacBook Air is coming soon
maybe as soon as WWDC or maybe even the
spring event which obviously that is not
happening and here are some leaks for it
well we have this one from digitimes
saying that the new Macbook Air with the
three nanometer M3 chip is launching in
the second half of 2023 and to me that
makes perfect sense because the MK tips
are on a one and a half year cycle so
the first one the M1 came out in
November of 2020 then about a year and a
half later in the summer of
2022 we got the M2 Chip so now it only
makes sense for the M3 to come around a
year and a half later which puts it
perfectly at October November at the
minimum at the earliest so the 13 inch
MacBook Air with M3 is not happening
until later this year and yes I do
believe Apple's gonna have enough three
nanometer chips from tsmc because Apple
has ordered the entire initial Supply
yes all of it no other brand Apple only
is getting these three nanometer chips
which is gonna give them a huge
Advantage for their iPhones their M3 Max
the MacBook Air and the iPad Pro that's
going to be amazing but now let's
finally get into what we should expect
at this month's March events and that is
the 15 inch MacBook Air and you know why
well because leaks are pointing to the
15-inch MacBook Air coming with the M2
Chip yes the same M2 that came out last
year and that just came to the Mac Mini
it's coming to the 15 inch MacBook Air
now I know a lot of you guys are
speculating on what could come to that
model well I think it's going to be
literally identical to the 13-inch
MacBook Air with the M2 Chip the only
differences will be between three and
five changes you have the larger 15-inch
display the larger battery the better
speakers due to the bigger chassis and
then potentially Wi-Fi 6E and Bluetooth
5.3 and the reason I say that is because
we just got an apple filing for
Bluetooth 5.3 and that's amid the rumors
of this new Macbook Air so it could get
that as well and just to add more
evidence to this back in June of 2022
Ming Chico talked about the 15-inch
MacBook saying that it could launch in
the second quarter of 2023 which starts
in April so the way I see it is this
15-inch MacBook Air gets announced at
the March event later this month but it
only ships in early April and that way
the timings match up now he did also say
that the name could be changed from the
MacBook Air and it could even come with
an M2 Pro chip which I personally don't
believe is going to happen I think it's
going to be just like the regular
13-inch just bigger so definitely expect
the 15-inch MacBook Air at the spring
event and now of course we have the
other product which is the Mac Pro
finally yes Apple said there's a
two-year timeline transition to Apple
silicon and yes they were late but only
a couple of months late if it comes at
this March event now getting into the
leaks we actually had an apple executive
who did an interview earlier this month
actually Yesterday by the time I'm
filming this he hinted at the Apple
silicon Mac Pro saying that they're
still working on it so that could be a
hint that it's coming later this month
now in terms of the actual design and
features Mark German said it's going to
look identical to the current Intel
model which makes sense because it's the
cheapest and easiest route for Apple to
do however it's gonna lack expandable
Ram that really sucks but it kind of
makes sense because of the unified
memory architecture and having Ram slots
would kind of mess up the whole thing
and ruin everything but we do have a
Saving Grace for the Mac Pro and that
was a leak from nine to five Mac where
within iOS 16.4 code there was
references to a new compute module which
I believe is basically an MPX card just
like we have right now for graphics but
a custom Apple card that slots into the
Mac Pro now there's a couple of ideas or
theories for this the first one is this
one that I agree with from Jeff Benjamin
saying that we could have the entire
brains on the card itself which you plug
in so it has everything not including
the networking storage but everything in
terms of the brains the soc chip the ram
everything on one big card you plug it
in and then when a new one comes out in
a couple years you take that one out you
put the new upgraded model in with the
M3 Ultra or the M4 Ultra whatever comes
you plug it in and swap it out that's
fully modular and that is amazing but
that might be a little bit of a stretch
because of the ties to iOS 16 so it
might actually just be a custom GPU card
that you slot in and it's not going to
take full advantage of Apple silicon and
the architecture but it's going to have
a ton of raw GPU performance and maybe
even extra extra CPU I don't know
probably not but you're gonna slot in a
card and get a big boost for things like
3D rendering and that's what I think it
could be either of those two scenarios
so with that said that's what you should
expect at this March spring event mainly
the 15-inch MacBook Air and the Mac Pro
and I think it's coming this spring
because WWDC is going to be focused on
the VR headset so they can't do the VR
headset and the Mac Pro at the same time
there's not enough time for all of that
jumped into one so that's why I think
Mac Pro right now let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign